[Music]
so you're fast oh yeah real
fast well if the uh fate of the world
ever comes down to who can win a 500
yard dash I have your number on speed
dial
I actually like
that oopsie
Daisy
Joker
sorry look at us I have you and you've
got none of your super friends here to
save you because uh you fired them
all so uh looks like it's time to say
goodbye wait
maybe there's something you
want what what do I want what do I want
what do I want uh let's see how about we
take off that mask and reveal your
identity on Tik Tok or how about I drive
your little tank car into a preschool
the possibilities are so
fun you're sick
Joker yeah I am sick what else do you
expect from a man who's raised by a
narcissistic mother who let her abusive
boyfriend beat her sweet little son it's
me only for that trauma to manifest Dune
to a disorder he laughs
uncontrollably inappropriate
moments like
that hold
that
what what do you mean what that's why
you you laugh it it's a medical
condition yes I thought you were just
insane and maniacal yeah no it's it's
just it's just a disorder the zolof
helps zolof helps yeah but you know what
was maniacal those Thugs who stole my
sign from my sign spinning job you were
a sign spinner it was a soulless job and
that turned me into the homicidal maniac
you see sitting before
you because you're from spinning
SIDS okay here's here's what happened
okay so the thugs stole my sign yeah
okay that you were spinning and then I
chased them to get my sign you got to
get that sign and then they beat me up
with the sign okay was it like a big
heavy metal sign no it was cardboard
they hit you with a card like a
cardboard sign yeah but it was a really
thick ply yeah yeah you know like a
moving box you know what I mean not like
an Amazon box but really you know what I
mean so you're spinning a thick ply sign
and some Riff Raff took it and popped
you with it and now you have to kill
kids and [__] well the trauma of the
whole sign spinning incident twisted my
guts traumatized me then I started
carrying this gun around you know to
protect myself and then it went off in
the children's hospital I lost my job as
a clown and
then
hold you worked as a
cloud well yeah I mean how else do you
think I can do this makeup yeah cuz you
could never just freestyle that this is
a lot for me it's like finding out
scarecrow with Scarecrow because he
played Scarecrow in a production of The
Wizard of
Oz just [__] kill me I'm sorry
[__] kill me shoot for the mouth hole
you want me to shoot you yeah why
because the more I learn about you the
Lamer you get and I'm getting lame by
association it's way cooler than that is
it yes let's go flop shoes
okay I got one for you okay you know
it's really really devious please
something give me something how about
this I dated my girlfriend for a whole 6
months and then I found out she he was
imaginary Isn't that
cool I just I just want to be very well
heard on this
point eat [__] [__] sorry eat [__]
[__] you clown car valet nothing was
better than this me just falling asleep
wondering why you might be the Way You
Are
is better than this [__] Lifetime
movie that I'm being forced to sit
through you're not Taxi Driver your Must
Love Dogs okay all
right how about this please this is some
really twisted stuff I want to believe
here it comes before I was the Joker
yeah all I wanted to do was make people
laugh this is good this is UN brand and
so I became a standup
comedian you heard open bicer so I did
some open mics and I did us some bringer
shows three drink minimums that kind of
thing and then I got on late night and
the host mocked me on the air on
National
Television it sounds like you just
bombed yeah no I didn't bomb I just they
didn't get how funny I was so I shot the
host in the the face most Comics just
you know Retreat into improv okay uh
well when I didn't kill I
killed oh God we deserve better Gotham
deserves better puns come on kill me you
hack stop I'm not a hack I'm not a
hack what what what
what is this are you doing the elain
it's my dance it's a physical
manifestation of me stepping into my
stepping into my new life of evil oh I I
didn't know you do interpretive dance
you you you are
cool really no what the [__] is this
bumpity boo Vlog your lab hey shut up we
live in a society oh great your greatest
contribution
a meme no one gets you're going to die
worse than the amade g bimp girl [__]
this I
quit I
prefer Jared
[Music]
Leto